we're gonna begin with this today guys
the Justice Department will release
Robert mullahs Russia report this
morning with some material removed as
required by law Attorney General William
bar there you see left his home a short
time ago he will hold a news conference
this morning before Congress and the
public get a chance to see this four
hundred page report now CBS News has
learned this that he will discuss the
redaction process reveal if president
Trump claimed executive privilege and
clarify recent interactions between the
White House and the Justice Department
Democrats accused Barr of trying to
protect the president this morning House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi and Senate
Democratic leader Chuck Schumer called
from Muller to testify on Capitol Hill
about the report Ouisa jiang is at the
White House where efforts to discredit
Muller have been going on for months we
should good morning good morning John
White House officials are really
downplaying the release of this report
focusing instead on what they call the
most important part of it the
conclusions which we have known for
weeks
one source describes it like this we
already know how the book ends echoing
president Trump that there was no
collusion in fact just minutes ago the
president tweeted that this is the
greatest political hoax of all time but
there is an acknowledgement throughout
the West Wing the report may reveal
damning details about the president and
his actions even if they do not rise to
the level of criminal activity sources
say mr. Trump himself is aware of that
but he's not worried the report will
cost him politically the White House has
reading teams in place stressing they do
not expect to get a copy of the report
early the president's personal attorneys
have a rebuttal plan a counter report
that's been in the works for months
President Trump will likely tout the
report's conclusions on the 20/20 road
to re-election late last night the
campaign texted a fundraising appeal to
supporters saying in part we need 1
million Patriots to stand with President
Trump before the Malheur report is
released tomorrow John all right we
should thank you CBS News well bringing
you bring you the Attorney General's
remarks this morning in a special report
live coverage begins around 9:30 8:30
central here on CBS I think one of the
things that we're gonna try and do here
at CBS 2 is not just cover the circus
around
and what he says she says or he says and
he says we're really gonna dig into the
substance of this and try and provide
our audience with the relevant
information so they can make a choice on
their own and they can read it as well
but we're gonna give the best analysis
we're getting a chance as you say to
glimpse the actual report redacted but
we will have had two summaries the
original four-page letter from the
Attorney General and then now he's going
to tell us some remarks at a press
conference before so there's a lot of
actual report to look at now that we've
seen all this summarizing there's a lot
to see here yeah
[Music]